sí
[Música]
mucho más exigente
astori
bienvenidos a esta emisión de los
observadores de france 24 esta calle
terán es una de las nuevas guaridas de
los drogodependientes en el sur de la
capital iraní en medio de los
transeúntes hombres mujeres consumen
anfetaminas y otras drogas durante todo
el día de este vídeo de más de dos
minutos muestra la explosión de consumo
de drogas en irak donde el número de
toxicómanos ha aumentado un 50% en diez
años para nuestro observador las
principales causas son la negligencia de
las autoridades y la crisis económica
que atraviesa el país ha olvidado baja
de amor y que para control coach de hoy
de admisión de la razón de este aumento
es que ya no hay un tratamiento ni
tampoco asistencia para los drogadictos
y hasta tics
en otras palabras en nuestra política
pública se les abandona a su suerte y
actualmente hay factores que fomentan la
adicción como la creciente pobreza y la
desigualdad social sin embargo la
presencia de estos tóxicos humanos en
las calles también depende de las
políticas de seguridad y de la voluntad
de la ley
no era thierry dol activo
a mí no vistas estas personas para optar
se calcula que entre 200.000 y 300.000
adictos viven en guardias en las calles
y el 10% de ellos son mujeres les
compran las drogas a los traficantes que
las inyectan o las consumidas y viven en
esas guaridas en la calle que se
encuentran principalmente en los barrios
y suburbios pobres en irán hay cientos
de centros de desintoxicación a los que
los drogodependientes son enviados a
menudo contra su voluntad por sus
familias y cuyos métodos son muy
controvertidos el pasado mes de enero un
vídeo mostraba como algunos hombres se
les obligaba a nadar en una piscina
temperaturas bajo cero y luego se les
insultaba y vuelve a acompañar a la
mayoría de las veces esos centros son
creados por personas que no son
absolutamente expertas en la materia lo
hacen solo para llenarse los bolsillos
[Música]
home el ángulo de armón emocionante
grado utilizan métodos de
desintoxicación que no son para nada
científicos
de hecho estos centros no son más que
otro tipo de cárcel que no están
registradas como tal especial hoy ni
cuota del indert la calidad de vida es
muy baja los adictos están retenidos en
condiciones drásticas en ponerte bien la
comida todos los servicios son servicios
mínimos y debido a estas condiciones
cuando los adictos son liberados después
de tres a seis meses vuelven a su
adicción en las calles
irán es vecino de afganistán uno de los
principales productores de droga en el
mundo en 2020 las autoridades iraníes
incautaron mil 150 toneladas de droga un
récord mundial esto no impide que los
consumidores obtengan dosis de drogas
duras a precios asequibles
ah
saltos o el derechas desde hace unas
semanas estos niños de la calle de un
barrio pobre en la capital de uganda
kampala practican gimnasia y es gracias
a este hombre llega mustafa de apenas 20
años llega aprendió gimnasia en el
orfanato donde creció apenas terminó sus
estudios decidió transmitir su pasión a
los otros niños de su barrio no tiene
los medios se entrena con dida de
youtube pero no tienen miedo de soñar en
grande por inscripción conmigo sin
estafa en el camino bueno tortillas los
niños no paraban de preguntarme
entrenador mustafa cuando nos va a dar
clases el hecho de que me llamarán
entrenador mustafa me motivó
les prometí que crearíamos un equipo de
gimnasia y acrobacia y que competiríamos
a nivel nacional incluso hasta olímpico
al principio fue un reto porque no
sabíamos dónde íbamos a entrenar
entrenamos en un terreno baldío de la
barriada de cut web por el momento no
tenemos equipos excepto las llantas de
parís
y las edades de los niños oscilan entre
los 3 y los 13 años y estos niños vienen
de la comunidad de la calle de los
campamentos de refugiados
[Música]
con la gimnasia los niños siempre están
ocupados los mantiene alejados de las
malas compañías de las drogas y de la
violencia doméstica
en uganda la gente tiene una imagen
negativa de la gimnasia pero queremos
romper esta imagen entrenando muy duro
con nuestros pocos medios y construyendo
un equipo nacional que un día
representará a uganda en los juegos
olímpicos si quieren apoyar la
iniciativa de digamos estafa no dude en
ponerse en contacto con él a través de
su página de facebook que ataca
gimnástic club
y hasta aquí los observadores por esta
semana si desea contactar a nuestra
redacción todos los contactos aparecen
en nuestra pantalla
envíenos fotos y vídeos aficionados y
quizás los próximos observadores de
france24 sean ustedes hasta pronto
[Música]